michael morbius discover who you're
meant to be
the bad guy
[Music]
yes
michael
what have you done i was trying to help
people
but the cure
it's curse
not cool
i have powers that can only be described
as superhumans
but there's a cost
now a face of choice
to hunt
and consume blood
or die
we all have monsters within us it's up
to us to control it
what if i can't
michael morbius
you've been given a gift not exactly
time to let go of what you used to be
discover who you're meant to be
all our lives we've lived with death why
shouldn't they know what it feels like
for a
change just accept who you are
the bad guy
more bs
holy water really
yeah you ever see lost boys story of my
life
a new marvel legend arrives exclusively
in movie theaters april 1st
you